ميدانيا كذلك قالت الاداره العسكريه في
انفجارات هزت المنطقه الواقعه جنوب شرقي
اوكرانيا
جنوبيه البلاد
انفجارات قويه بعد رصد اطلاق صواريخ من
بحر ازوف
وقالت المتحدثه باسم منطقه عمليات الجنوب
الاوكراني نتاليا ان القوات الروسيه
تستهدفت منطقه اوديسا بطائرات مسيره اسقطت
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه ثلاثا منها
مشيره الى ان احدى الطائرات اصابت هدفا من
دون تسجيل اصابات في صفوف المدنيه
الوضع هادئا في منطقه اوديسا كغيرها من
مناطق الجنوب يحاول العدو ايجاد التكتيكات
جديده لتجاوز انظمه دفاعاتنا الجويه
اسقطنا ثلاثه طائرات من نوع شاهد فوق
منطقه اوديس وطائره واحده اصابت احد
الاهداف ولا اصابات بين المدنيين استهدف
الهجوم الصاروخي مجددا ويحاول العدو رفع
مستوى ازمه انقطاع المياه في المنطقه
ويستهدف منشات الحيويه
في المقابل اعلنت سلطات دنيتك المواليه
لروسيا استهداف القوات الاوكرانيه وسط
مدينه دانيت
واوضحت السلطات مسيرتين اوكرانيتين
استهدفتا منطقتين في المدينه ما اوقع
دمارا كبيرا
للمتابعه
مراسلنا حسان مسعود حسان التطورات
المرتبطه الانفجارات التي سمع ذوي لديك
فيولوجيا وكذلك ما جرى في اوديسا من اسقاط
القوات الاوكرانيه للسيارات روسيه
مريم قبل قليل فقط اعلنت القوات الجويه ان
الهجوم الصاروخي وكذلك بالمسيرات خلال
الليل كان يستهدف منشات البنيه التحتيه
الحساسه وكذلك وصفتها بالحرجه وهذا يشير
الى طبيعه الاهداف التي كان يجري العمل
على استهدافها خلال هذه الليله اوضحت
بالتفاصيل هذه الهجمه الصاروخيه وطبيعه
الصواريخ التي وجهت نحو المناطق
الاوكرانيه لا سيما المنطقه الجنوبيه
الشرقيه قالت ان ثلاث صواريخ او ثلاثه
صواريخ من طراز
كينجال وهي صواريخ فرد صوتيه بالاضافه الى
صواريخ كروز من طراز 22.47 وجهت نحو
الاراضي الاوكرانيه لكنها قالت انها لم
تصب هدفها التي وجهت اليه لكنها كانت تريد
ان تصيب تلك المنشات الحرجه كما وصفتها
بالاضافه ايضا الى
المنطقه الجنوبيه تحديدا منطقه اوديسا
باربع سيارات من طراز شاهد وقالت انها
اسقطت ثلاث مسيرات من هذه
المسيرات الانتحاريه الا ان احدى المسيرات
اصابت هدفها دون الافصاح عن طبيعه هذا
الهدف هذا يشير الى ان الهجمه الصاروخيه
وكذلك بالمسيرات كانت تريد ان تصل الى
اهداف في عمق المناطق التي تقع على اطراف
هذه الجبهه الممتده والمشتعله من الشرق
باتجاه اقصى الجنوب لاسيما المناطق
الشماليه من هذه الجبهه وكذلك جنوب هذه
الجبهه وحول تطورات الميدان في الجبهه
اشاره المتحدث باسم جبهه تافريا التي تشمل
جنوب مقاطعه دنيا وكذلك جنوب مقاطعه
زابولوجيا ان القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول ان
تتقدم باتجاه مناطق كبرى وهي مناطق في
اقصى جنوب منطقه زابولوجيا وكذلك منطقه
لكنها ما زالت بعيده عن هذه المناطق يتحدث
المتحدث باسم هذه الجبهه عن كيلو متر واحد
تقدمت عبره القوات الاوكرانيه باتجاه
مواقع القوات الروسيه لكنه في ذات الوقت
يؤقت يؤكد ان القوات الروسيه كانت تقوم
بهاجمات عند محور جنوب مقاطعه وتحاول ان
تتجه نحو المواقع الاوكرانيه لكنه يؤكد في
ذات الوقت ان ايا من المواقع الاوكرانيه
لم يتم خسارتها خلال هذه الهجمات هذه
التطورات اتت ايضا في ظل حديث خلال الليل
عن اطلاق صواريخ باليستيه من جهه وايضا
توجيهي مسيرات انتحاريه باتجاه شمال
اوكرانيا وكذلك محيط العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف